هذا التحول الذي حدث في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه عبر التشريعات المختلفه عبر
الانفتاح على الحياه بكل تجلياتها على
الانفتاح على الاخر وعلى اسئله الاسئله
كان شبه مغيبه هل هذا الانفتاح وتلك
التشريعات هو الذي سمح لاصوات كانت خافته
في الماضي
للظهور للخروج الى الضوء اذا صح القول هذا
الانفتاح على مستوى التشريعي والمستوى
السياسي هو ايضا انعكاس الانفتاح
الاجتماعي
وحراك فكري عميق واسئله
مختلفه طرحتها شرائح المجتمع المختلفه
المجتمع السعودي اتوقع يعني النسبه
الغالبه فيهم من الشباب والشابات
وهؤلاء يتطلعون للمستقبل ويريدون ان
ياخذون هذه التجارب
ومن هذا التجارب الفكريه هناك مؤتمر مؤتمر
الفلسفه التي تنظم وزاره الثق العام
الماضي اجتمع نخبه فلاسفه العالم في
الرياض لمده ثلاثه ايام يتناقشون
ويتاملون ويفكرون الجميل او يمكن الاجمل
ان هناك حضن اجتماعي كان هناك شبان وشابات
كان هناك نقاش يعني المجتمع السعودي لم
يكن
متلقيا فقط لكن مشاركا ومتسائلا وتدخل في
حوارات معمقه مع هؤلاء الفلاسفه يعني انا
بعض الزملاء الفلاسفه من امريكا ومن كندا
كانوا يشيرون الى الطبيعه الاجتماعيه
للفلسفه بالسعوديه بمعنى يقولون نحن
اساتذه جامعات
ما المعتاد في المؤتمرات الفلسفيه هي انها
تكون للاساتذه ويحضرها في احسن الاحوال
الاساتذه والطلاب الجامعات خصوصا دراسات
العليا لكن ما حدث في الرياض ان الحضور
كان متنوع جدا كان الاطباء يحضرون وكان
المهندسين يحضرون كان المختصين في
الفنانين يحضرون الشعراء يحضرون الادباء
يحضرون كان الحضور من الاجيال مختلفه